wir sind einen weiten Weg gekommen wir
haben einen Tag für 1 € gegessen dann
für 25 10 20 50 100 und heute springen
wir einfach direkt zur größten Banknote
die es gibt oder genau genommen nicht
mehr so wirklich gibt 500 €. das ist
nicht 51er sondern 10 es fühlt sich
vollkommen absurd an dieses Geld in der
Hand zu haben weil ich meine ich muss ja
nichts vormachen immer man verdient
natürlich gutes Geld aber das einfach
mal so in der Hand zu haben ist
irgendwie bisschen bescheuert dass man
das an einem Tag für Essen ausgeht
deshalb mal gucken wie viel von dem Geld
überhaupt ausgeben können aber ich habe
mir was überlegt kommen wir später ein
Video dazu außerdem ist das Video heute
unterstützt von finanzguru dafür schon
mal vielen lieben Dank also haben wir
erstmal überlegt und sind dann einkaufen
gefahren für einen besonderes besonderes
Frühstück
legen wir also los mit dem Frühstück wir
haben wirklich traumhafte Zutaten vor
uns liegen insgesamt hat das Ganze
ungefähr 75 Euro gekostet und ich habe
mich wirklich nicht zurückgehalten ich
habe eigentlich so das teuerste gekauft
was ich finden konnte also wir wollten
ja eigentlich zu diesem anderen
kaviar-geschäft das leider zu hatte
ein bisschen Champagner Kaviar Frühstück
machen und die kavi Apotheke hat zu
unglaublich aber zum Glück können wir ja
ein bisschen kochen wir machen das
einfach selbst wird schon da hätten wir
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr auf
den Tisch hauen können aber 75 € ist
eine Menge Geld und wir haben aber auch
glaube ich jetzt genug Zutaten um ein
paar Portion davon zu machen deshalb
wenn man das dann vielleicht am Ende
wieder Vergleich mit Restaurant wer weiß
vielleicht lohnt sich ja sogar wir haben
ein wunderbares Sauerteigbrot perfekte
Grundlage um die anderen Zutaten
wirklich scheinen zu lassen vor allem
ein Lachsfilet 200 g 15 € und Kaviar 50
Gramm vom Störer 50 € dazu noch ein paar
Kräuter Dill Schnittlauch eine Zwiebel
und creme fraîche Brot anrösten
Lachs KAV der Kräuter bisschen Zwiebel
ich würde sagen wir legen los mit Brot
anrösten das ist eigentlich das beste
was wir als erstes machen können ich
sage ehrlich 75 Euro hat der Einkauf
gekostet dieses Brot hier 5 Euro was
natürlich viel ist aber gemessen am Rest
nicht so viel und ich glaube dass das
schon der Star vom Frühstück wird ich
meine klar 5 Euro wir haben die Serie
angefangen mit 1 € und dafür einen Tag
lang gegessen mehr schlecht als recht
muss man natürlich sagen von Zwiebeln
schneiden fühlst du mich nicht aber beim
Brot schneiden ich liebe dieses Brot
einfach deshalb einfach mal schaudert
Bäckerei Brot hier in Köln bergisches
Viertel beste leben wir nehmen uns
ordentlich Butter und lassen Sie einmal
auf der planscher schmelzen und so
rösten wir jetzt alles goldbraun an
nicht mal 5 Minuten später sieht das
ganze so aus jetzt lass mir das Ganze
gut abkühlen so dass es ein crunchbehält
aber die Creme fresh nicht zum Schmelzen
bringen das ist die max-technik wirklich
auf einer Seite liegt die halt so
Feuchtigkeit und so kann es von allen
Seiten so man kann auch so machen das
Brot kühlt und ich schneide mir ganz
ganz feine Streifen Zwiebel einfach
einfach nur so als geschmacklicher
Akzent nicht weil es irgendwie groß was
bewirken soll sondern so hauchten
genauso fein schneiden wir jetzt auch
Schnittlauch und Dill wir wollen auf
jeden Fall richtig präzise arbeiten gib
mir nicht Mühe jetzt alles geschnibbelt
machen wir weiter mit dem Lachs ich
wollte ihn gerade aufreißen aber ich
glaube das das ist nicht nicht
entsprechend seiner Würde wir machen das
mal so vorsichtig auf okay sogar so
schön auf Gold ein Stück muss man immer
probieren Qualitätstest
sehr lecker davon schneide ich mir jetzt
ein paar Scheibchen und dann nehme ich
den Grill hole ich die Creme frischen
[Musik]
jetzt streuen wir ein bisschen
Schnittlauch und jetzt unser Kaviar vom
stören so kleinen Häufchen ablegen jetzt
ist es schon wieder was anderes finde
ich wenn man hört 75 Euro weil es sind
halt fünf kaviarschnitten also dann das
hier ist unser Frühstück am Tag an dem
wir für 500 € Essen ich weiß nicht wann
ich zuletzt mit so viel Aufmerksamkeit
und Hingabe und Brot geschmiert habe
aber ich würde sagen probieren einfach
ich bin auch stolz ein bisschen sieht
gar nicht so schlecht aus ne Foto machen
auf dem Teller und so ein bisschen so
großen wo direkt alles dabei ist dass
ihr schmecken aus
so wichtig ne dieses Sauerteigbrot ultra
knusprig bin es auch genau richtig und
gut dass es wieder abgekühlt ist und die
Zutaten glänzen aber der Lachs finden
dich schmeckt nochmal deutlich anders
als herkömmlich verräucherlass oder auf
jeden Fall Zeit weil das ist ja die
haben es ja so erklärt das ist ja das
mittelfiletstück vom Lachs genau
es ist ultra lecker ne aber wenn ich zum
Beispiel zurück denke an zehn Euro als
wir bei der italienischen Ape
gefrühstückt haben das ist auch auf
seine eigene Art und Weise unschlagbar
ist aber auch nicht zu vergleichen
eigentlich nicht zu vergleichen aber die
Wirklichkeit die wir danach hatten die
war fast auf demselben Level sehr
leckeres Frühstück ich freue mich vor
allem das jetzt auch mit den anderen zu
teilen ich hoffe Dir schmeckt es schon
den anderen gleich bestimmt auch ich
konnte nicht mehr warten
und wir sehen uns beim Mittagessen
wieder und hier seht ihr den Einkauf
fürs heutige Mittagessen auch das Kochen
wir wieder insgesamt hat der Einkauf
55,56 € gekostet wir haben aber auch
noch die Sahne dabei und ein paar Sachen
die wir vorher schon hatten aber man
kann so viel sagen ich habe auf jeden
Fall einen guten Überblick über meine
Finanz und wie viel ich am Ende übrig
haben werde werde ich mit finanzguru
herausfinden die auch das heutige Video
freundlicherweise sponsern noch einmal
für die von euch die finanzguru
vielleicht noch gar nicht kennen
finanzguru hilft dir deine Kosten zu
tracken und immer einen Überblick zu
behalten über deine Verträge Ausgaben
freizeitkosten und eigentlich alles was
von deinem Konto abgeht lad dir die App
herunter und verknüpft dein Konto oder
deine Content mit der finanzguru App
egal ob Privatkonto Kreditkarte Paypal
oder dein Aktiendepot alles lässt sich
über wenige Klicks in die App einfügen
sogar dein Krypto wolle kannst du
hinzufügen so könnt Ihr sehen ob er
vielleicht zu viel für Lebensmittel
ausgibt weniger essen gehen solltet oder
Sparpotenzial habt habt ihr euer Konto
erstmal verbunden habt ihr eine
Übersicht über alle Verträge und Abgaben
überflüssige Verträge kannst du sogar
mit einem Fingertip rechts sicher über
die App kündigen die App selbst ist
komplett kostenlos über meinen Code Max
eins kannst du finanzguru plus aber für
einen Monat kostenlos testen mit
finanzguru plus hast du immer eine
Übersicht wie viel Geld du im laufenden
Monat ausgeben kannst ohne ins Minus zu
gelangen zudem kannst du dir smarte
Budgets festlegen so wie es für das
heutige Video getan habe du kannst deine
Ausgaben analysieren und hast einen
Überblick darüber wie sich deinen
Kaufverhalten geändert hat ladet also
die finanzgure App über meinen Link in
der Beschreibung runter registriert euch
und nutzt finanzguru plus mit meinem
Code max1 einen Monat lang kostenlos und
jetzt machen wir trüffelpasta und als
erstes tun wir zwei fein geschnittene
Schalotten in Olivenöl lassen die ein
bisschen an Geschmack gewinnen extra
fein geschnitten weil wir wollen am Ende
ja nicht so große Stückchen in unserer
trüffelsoße haben sollen wir wollen so
eine richtig cremige feine edle Soße
haben in unserer Soße brauchen wir
außerdem unsere
Nudelwasser wir Kochen mit frischen
Nudeln die brauchen drei bis vier
Minuten wir kochen die 12 Minuten vor
und dann fertig in der Pfanne mit Sahne
da wirklich das wird wild ich bin echt
gespannt ne das ist so ein bisschen
Freestyle weil ich finde es gibt keinen
also ich habe wirklich geschaut nicht
ich finde nicht ein Rezept für die
Trüffel passt da wie ich sie liebe ist
jetzt nicht streng italienisch oder
irgendwas sondern es zieht halt einfach
alles darauf ab so eine richtig krank
cremige geile trüffelpasta zu bekommen
und ich werde tun was getan werden muss
weil ich habe so Bock darauf anderthalb
Minuten sind schon vorbei echt die
restliche Zeit koche ich die Nudeln
jetzt fertig in der Soße das heißt ich
hole sie rüber und schon vorgekocht und
gegeben sie mit ein bisschen Nudelwasser
klar das hat jetzt nicht viel stärker
angenommen gerade wenn es frische Nudeln
sind rüber in unsere Pfanne gleich noch
ordentlich Parmesan drunter heben damit
das auch richtig cremig wird so wie viel
Sahne ist das da drin waren so 600 ml
300 werden wir auf jeden Fall brauchen
hier drüben schon mal den Parmesan vor
wir geben den geriebenen Parmesan oben
drauf und heben ihn jetzt runter
boah sieht schon echt gut aus war eine
tolle Cremigkeit die wir schon erzählt
haben dafür Butter noch ein bisschen
heute wieder Fitness Essen heute wieder
Fitness essen ja jetzt nur noch
portionieren frischen Trüffel drüber und
genießen rüffele den jetzt wird es
richtig teuer
oha boah guck mal wie perfekt runter
[Gelächter]
aber also komm das sieht doch wunderbar
aus oder da ist das Ding jetzt also ich
bin echt zufrieden es sieht aus wie
etwas für das man im Restaurant aufwärts
von 20 € bezahlt auf jeden Fall und wir
haben vier Portion wieder gemacht für 55
€. nee merkt schon selbst ich denke auch
dass die Zutaten im Restaurant
vielleicht nicht immer so gut sind wie
hier kann mir vorstellen diese Portionen
Restaurant 720 €, 50
aber würde man auch gerne so viel dafür
bezahlen das ist die Frage die
beantworten jetzt
boah wow Cremigkeit sehr krass und durch
die verschiedenen Trüffel Erzeugnisse
auch so ein wirklich intensiver
Trüffelgeschmack ja noch nie Trüffel so
gegessen ja und der schmeckt ganz dezent
einfach ne es schmeckt nach fast nichts
ich finde es ernst krass genau ein
bisschen froh weil ich habe das Gefühl
ich muss mich so anstrengen um die
Gerichte teuer zu machen dass wir heute
abend außer Haus essen die Küche bleibt
kalt heute Abend ich habe solche immer
gewünscht dass sie auch viel Koch in dem
Format das habe ich jetzt gemacht wir
gehen einfach richtig teuer ist essen
wir befinden uns voritor einem
japanischen Restaurant welches von außen
sehr schick aussieht ich habe mal die
Speisekarte gegoogelt ist teuer perfekt
für das heutige Video also gehen wir
rein gönnen uns was ich weiß noch nicht
genau was es gibt aber ich glaube hier
können wir es uns richtig gut gehen
lassen los geht's
interessant guck mal wenn Nigiri schnell
nicht überhört
einer Nigiri wer ist gerade nicht vor
Augen hat die kleinen reißschiffchen 12
Euro
[Musik]
wir bestellen einfach und dann gehen wir
erst darauf ein
[Musik]
also dann probieren wir mal ich bin sehr
gespannt ich glaube wir starten mit der
Special
rolls-trüffel dabei grünen Spargel ich
tipp direkt
[Musik]
verrückt oder Avocado noch dabei so eine
gewisse Schärfe es waren jetzt ein zwei
drei vier fünf sechs sieben acht fieses
höre ich kann es gar nicht einschätzen
wie das schmecken wird was kommt als
erstes Säure ist schon sehr sehr cremig
das Ganze durch diesen
da drin ist Avocado sehr cremig so sehr
herzhaft durch die Soße die unten auch
gepinselt ist durch den Trüffel und sehr
knackig auf jeden Fall mit dem grünen
Spargel glaube ich probiere hier schon
mal direkt weiter
wie krank unten drunter ist nämlich ein
bisschen Wasabi dann ist das so ein
bisschen flambiert von unten so dass es
nicht ganz roh ist es langsam man hat
trotzdem noch so röstar warum
unglaublich leckere Trüffel man denkt
okay mehr geht nicht das hier ist Turbo
Thun auch das beste Stück vom blufin
Tuner auch hausgemachte Sojasauce und
schmeckt sehr lecker ja ich muss jetzt
mich auf Turbo konzentrieren
für mich top das war genau wirklich man
schmeckt die Qualität wie gut die
Zutaten sind kennst du das du isst etwas
und das ist etwas teurer und während du
es ist
ärgerst du dich dass du so viel dafür
bezahlen musst hier vergisst man das
eher oder das ist einfach so es schmeckt
so elegant das schmeckt so luxuriös wie
das für was man bezahlt also sehr sehr
lecker
danke sehr wollen wir probieren das hat
schon so eine 40 obendrauf im extra
vagio Messer bekommen ich probiere
einfach mal erstmal ohne alles
das ist wirklich so gut ich wollte so
dadurch beißen
Weg unglaublich man denkt okay wie kann
essen weil das muss ja für sich selbst
stehen aber die schmeckt so lecker
perfekt gearbeitet ne wirklich
wunderschön
auch so eine intensive Jury haben wir
noch nie gegessen auch so ich vergesse
auch gerade das Video in dem wir uns
befinden sondern weil das ist so lecker
geil also wirklich noch deutlich mehr
als erwartet hätte ich würde sagen wir
genießen das auch ohne Kamera und dann
sehen wir uns für ein paar abschließende
Worte noch mal wieder okay Leute das
war's dann also es war wirklich ein
würdiges Ende würdiges Highlight für den
heutigen Tag ich habe noch nie so gut es
war gegessen gucken wir mal gemeinsam
die App 175 € habe ich ausgegeben das
heißt ich habe noch 178,18 € zur
Verfügung ich könnte jetzt eine Flasche
Champagner kaufen oder irgendwas aber
ich habe wirklich mehr genossen mir mehr
gegönnt als mir eigentlich lieb ist
deshalb lassen wir es dabei ich Stock
das ganze wie gesagt noch mal auf 500
auf spend das Ganze an die Kölner Tafel
und bedanke mich auch dafür dass es
überhaupt möglich war bei finanzguru
fürs unterstützen das Videos danke an
euch fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten
Mal wir sehen uns ciao